having previously survived a brain
aneurysm
emma v anzon had a kidney transplant in
july
and everyone thank you for thinking of
me thank you for your prayers and your
thoughts
but her daughter says they feared the
worst when their mother tested positive
for covert 19
and was taken to hospital she called me
and said do not send me to the icu
i cannot go in there once i go in there
that's my end
i'm so sorry that will be my end if i
was ever taken to the icu
unfortunately she had to go in
and
i wasn't able to speak with her
the 57 year old had moved to northern
ireland from the philippines
devoted to nursing colleagues on duty in
covert wards
say she always put others first how
important was nursing to her
she was born a nurse because right from
the start
even before she took up nursing she was
caring you know for
families you know elders and everyone
else
and then she came over you know as a
nurse and even up to the last minute you
know
um she said she would die as a nurse
heartbroken by the fact that their
mother died alone
her daughters fear people are not taking
the second wave
seriously i'm furious and angry
this is not a joke it costs thousands of
lives
and it's only set to get worse as we
enter the the
colder colder months and into christmas
as well
proudly dressed in her nurses uniform at
her own request
emma's body was cremated last weekend
one of her three daughters
still recovering from coronavirus only
able to watch from a distance
in her car saturday just gone
which was my mother's funeral is i would
say
the worst day of my life i
had all these emotions rushing through
me
and yet we weren't allowed to comfort
one another
the embrace the warmth that you would
normally feel was taken away
it was a cold funeral for the warmest
person
i've ever known david blevins
sky news belfast